thousand you know you didn't see a lot
of it but your your your son brought you
to the last one the endgame one oh yeah
so I mean I you know there's a lot of
folding of clothes to do at home so you
know so anyway so I I said well why
don't we all going to see endgame we'll
we'll go as a family would be a lovely
thing and so but maybe you could help me
so I you know bit of the story and so
one of my sons did a PowerPoint oh it
was so good he did a PowerPoint
presentation of the whole story up to
the end of infinity war and went through
the whole thing he's really he's a
mathematician he's very direct he'll sit
there and think you go watch the film
but he'll tell you in one sentence with
this incredible brain so he did this
power presentation and then a little
quiz and just to test that we were
listening marks on the tangi yeah but
it's because why he did it is because he
knows that if we were in the cinema I
would be the one game what's the in
green why why is he so hungry that's why
he did this polymerization it was very
helpful I feel you can't prejudge people
but you seem to me like the sort of
person who would be a big fan of these
films
nice day right it's very nice to say I
mean love these film hey don't be so
rude you don't know I've never seen them
[Applause]
yeah and I'm not just doing this because
of what you didn't know okay true you
know I just don't know where to start
now with them what should I start with
right there's already a PowerPoint
presentation getting you right up does
this might sound like a stupid question
it's endgame the last one it's the most
recent one where's my phone
you're not going today are you doing
movie with them I don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
you just I don't know Bruno's really you
do
No we'll salt now because I wouldn't be
terrible if we got you fired
no no but but yes you are okay no it's
supposed to be over okay
that was supposed to be the end that's
why it was hilarious yeah yeah so you
could work back for the title end game
yes yes
[Music]